I want to congratulate you yeah I've you
know just had a birthday what did I do
you had a baby since I last saw you you
were on the show recently and you were
extremely pregnant why did I do that
I do it was great you were very funny
but I mean how the baby was born what
two months ago yeah that's incredible
and are you back to doing stand-up yet
or any oh no no I I'm I really want to
just spend as much time as I can with my
baby in her nanny right now well this is
I mean I I've been through this twice
and he's been through it twice where we
have little kids and this is this is the
real tough part you've got very young I
know and this is actually my nursing
dress it had spit up on it and then when
I got here your people kind of cleaned
it up for me and I put some gold on and
yeah well you know we have I think we
have a photo of you in the hospital
shortly after the birth you and your
husband Moshe and I love that you both
seem pretty disinterested in the human
life that you've created you want to
talk about that congratulations on your
new prop yeah pretty much sums up our
family right there who we are as a
family what's going on there what's to
explain your c-section
hold your applause yeah it was you know
it was it was very scary you know cuz I
actually had a planned c-section there's
that there's a term in England it's too
posh to push have you heard that yeah
basically like why bother pushing you're
probably gonna have a c-section anyway
so I scheduled mine right so it was
scheduled for 10 o'clock and then by
1007 there was just the bloody baby was
on my chest like did that happen to it
like this cut it's called skin-to-skin
and they were like oh you have to do
skin-to-skin yeah they want the baby to
be up against the moms as baby's skin to
be on the moms the baby they're angling
me and it was really bloody and I just
wanted them to wash it you're describing
up
you're describing it like a monster
attack - this is newborn human life that
you created stuff on it I just thought
they would like clean it it would smell
good or help you're still not sure the
child's gender yeah you keep calling it
it yeah
also the c-section it was like you know
the scariest day of my life but for
these doctors they do them like every
hour so it was just like a very routine
procedure they're talking about politics
like a doctor has got his hands inside
me he's tugging the baby out and he
started talking about Trump and I was
like excuse me I was on drugs and I was
like excuse me please I stopped talking
about Trump I don't want my the first
words my daughter hears to BP tape yeah
you know so you are I'm guessing you're
not a trump supporter I'm just reducing
that no but I have to say I'm obsessed
with Trump supporters like whenever I'm
driving down the street and I see a
Trump bumper sticker I always like speed
up to see who's driving like I just want
to know what they look like and like
it's never you know some guy in a suit
jacket smoking a pipe listening to all
things considered no every time it's
someone who looks like they know how to
use every part of the opossum
I saw a car the other day it had two
bumper stickers one said Trump 2020 very
optimistic there's going to be a 2020
yeah and then the other one said enough
with the science enough with this enough
what the science is a bumper sticker
like they don't want to hear any more
about science yeah like it's up for
debate yeah like and it's like let me
get this straight sir your car runs on
science you got GPS in there to take you
to Family Court you have in case of
minority approaches your vehicle you got
GPS you might I don't know right well
okay yeah you're gonna be fine the you
made a lot of friends here
you